sternenexplosion von der erde aus
sichtbar das wird jetzt klar in fünf
jahren können wir die forscher mit
calvin coolidge berichten von der erde
auf eine nova wenn also einen helligkeit
aufbruch kleiner zeigt den namen bekam
die nova also neu übrigens im november
572 von cabral
eine beobachtung am sternenhimmel nannte
er nova da etwas heller leuchten für
eine neben neuen stern hielt aber darf
man eine nova nicht mit einer supernova
verwechseln
dabei wird der stern so gewinnen eine
andere form gebracht eine nova ist also
nur einhelligkeit aufbruch der durch die
verschmelzung in diesem fall von zwei
sternen entsteht ding so als könnte uns
da etwas wirklich spektakuläres erwarten
die beiden sterne des doppelsterns kec
983 2227 stehen sich tatsächlich nach
die party beiden sterne teilen eine
einzige atmosphäre wie verehrt müsse in
einer gemeinsamen schale
es ist eine eins zu einer million franc
dass man eine solche explosion
vorhersagen kann so etwas ist noch nie
zuvor gelungen erklärte lorenz müller
vom calvin coolidge im jahr 2022 würde
diese enge konsultationen dann in einer
nova ihr ende finden die beiden sterne
überschreiten dann die roch grenze die
kollidieren hat und zitat das wäre ein
bedeutendes ereignis nicht nur für die
wissenschaft sondern auch weil es die
menschen auf der straße faszinieren kann
wenn die vorhersage stimmt dann wäre
dies das erste mal in der geschichte
dass eltern auf eine dunkle stelle am
himmel zeigen können und sagen rät
kinder dort versteckt sich ein stern der
balkan fell aufleuchten wird so matt
oberrot vom college wann genau an
welchem tag sich das szenario ereignen
wird das ist noch nicht bekannt sobald
wir ein genaueres datum in erfahrung
bringen können werden wir euch natürlich
die auf klicks auf dem laufenden halten
um das auf keinen fall zu verpassen habe
ich einen sensationellen tipp für euch
klick hier
da gibt es das abo kostenlos natürlich
und ansonsten bis dann ja dran und
schaue mir videos fertig sein